Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and I'm going to introduce to you our stop-fighting cancer and start treating the cause
course
now
What are my passions in life really and I believe my spiritual gift is to teach and
In that I want to take complex
Concepts and break them down into usable pieces of information
Because truly I believe my quote here knowledge is beautiful, but it's really the ability to apply that knowledge
That makes it key we could have a head full of information
But if we can't really apply it to our life to see some differences it really is useful
And I hear that over all the years of taking care of patients of all sorts of different
Diseases that that was their biggest thing they might have known a lot of stuff
But it's really the ability to apply that that becomes difficult and especially if you
You know receive a serious diagnosis of cancer and start telling your friends
You get people coming out of the woodwork for you to do this try this because my sister's friends brother did this and
And you sometimes feel like you're drinking from a fire hose and I understand that that's why we're trying
To break this down into usable pieces of information the course really stemmed
As stemming from my book my book stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause is available to you
You can buy it from us our store you can buy it from Amazon the first edition came out
I think about 10 years ago or so. This is the third edition now and it's like 600 pages
Well, that's like drinking from a fire hose. I don't want that's not what I want to produce
So then that kind of birthed the idea of let's take these concepts put them into a course where people can take that
That information and have bite-sized pieces that they can move forward with and see life changes with
So in our stop fighting cancer course, you really get lifetime access to all my constant updates because this field is
Constantly changing. I'm constantly studying reading reports if I read about another thing that could benefit
Somebody with a cancer diagnosis. I get to make a video about it
I got to put information about it and that's all going up on this course
This is a living course. That's what I call our courses living courses because they're constantly changing and improving and adding to
They have to life changes information comes out what we do 10 years ago
We you know, it was different than what we know now and there's like
suppressed remedies that are slowly leaking through that I want people to know about
So you get lifetime access to all of that through my course
You get lifetime access to our specific protocols that change too as I see something work better for different people
I got to add that to a protocol
You get suppressed remedies and new innovations you get all of that in this course now in through the course
I have multiple modules and I add modules right now
We have seven modules in the stop fighting cancer course first module
I talk about the natural band-aid approach not to take
Nutrition and diet and use it as a band-aid not dealing with causes that can be equally
As much of a problem is oh, I have a headache. I'm going to take some aspirin not ever asking why I have the headache
You have to deal with the why I mean that has been the key
Passion of my practice when I practiced for my whole lifetime
Deal with the why never stop asking why dig to that why figure that out deal with that you're gonna have the best
You know results to that. That's what I really wrap up in module two what I call it the Conner's method. I used to teach
My cancer fighting principles to other practitioners
This is years ago. I used to have courses for other practitioners
They'd come to my office. I teach them a weekend seminar and how to take care of people nutritionally
Dietarily and stuff. I actually have one of those full videos up on this module
So I go through kind of our approach the way I think through these things a very pragmatic and
Trying to to to find the best approach for every single person and module three
We dig in to that reason why find the cause you may not ever be able to do you know a
Full biopsy report to the cause of your specific cancer
But you need to dig to these things. There's a reason why and if you don't deal with the toxicities in your environment that you've been exposed to that has led to your disease
You know, that's you're not gonna get as good a result you have to dig to that to that cause and start treating that cause
That's really what our whole approach is all about
Then how do you address the cancer itself?
We can't say treat we can't say cure we can't say any of those kind of things and really we don't want to we want to address the reason
Why it's there and then get into some specific protocols cancer by cancer different types of cancer all through the way
I have all my specific protocols in here that you can follow if you have this type of breast cancer or this type of
A prostate cancer or a metastasis. What should you do if I am a testicist in the bone?
I address those things and I am constantly adding to those protocols through here that you can look at you can follow you can get some some
very
applicable information
That's the key thing to be able to apply this knowledge and then I talk about other tools
I talk about the right machine, but there's other tools too that you can use
P.E.M.F
Intervenous therapies
Ozone therapies
Hyperthermia therapies
That's where we get into module 5 and dealing with these other therapies
I'm a dealing with knife frequency therapies with people with serious disease since the late 90s
I'm pretty good at this in programming people's knife machine for their specific
Disorder and you can buy a right machine right through our course and you can buy these other therapies through a course
Through our course as a course member as well that gives you the ability to do that.
Then we talk about cleaning up your environment cleaning up not just your physical environment around you,
but your emotional environment and your inner environment of your body, detoxification and how to deal with that
And then we look at that spiritual emotional psychological component as well in module 7
And that is a constant
It's constant basically work and progress in all our lives. That's what sanctification is. You're constantly working towards
Holyness and trying to see what God's purpose in all this is and work through that and be okay with everything that you've been given.
That's in module 7.
Then through the course you can actually become a full private member.
And only through the course you have that ability and through a full private membership
That's when you can actually get on our weekly Zoom calls, ask me different questions and you have a full different membership site that's involved with that.
Then there's huge benefits that go along with that. Also through the course you can have the ability to purchase a right that I personally program for you based upon your condition and what other things you want programmed in there.
Maybe you have a spouse with some other issues and maybe diabetes or something like that. Well, that can be requested and I will put that program together specifically for you.
Also through the course you can purchase a full genetic review which you get the full read your genes course for free with our genetic review.
You're going to print out of your most specific things that we want you to deal with along with a 250 page full review of your genetics.
It's very, very comprehensive. Our desire is that you just constantly keep asking why our desire is that you keep constantly seeking.
But our real desire is that you're able to take the information that you get when you do those things and be able to apply it.
That's what this course is all about. It's lifetime access to everything that I've done to get to this point.
I've been in practice since 1986 and have been seeking out answers from God to help everybody that he sends me since that time.
And now I basically converge that information into our course to give to people that they'll be able to apply this knowledge that God has given me to their life and to be able to help and help their family.
That's what this course is all about. That's what all our courses are all about.
It's about digging in, asking why finding the best results for you, having personalized ability to deal with everything that's going on in your life.
And I just trust and know that you're going to be blessed through this course. And that's my prayer for you. Thanks so much.